listen my favorite game that I have the
bet in my life you were a kid but one of
the biggest games I had a bet in high
school I put everything I had I borrowed
money
I bet money I didn't have Dallas Cowboys
played the San Francisco 49ers and the
NFC and division finals
the 49ers was 16 and 1 I know that
there's a lot of people in the football
people out there and you're like Joey
you're wrong maybe they were 4 they lost
one game what did San Francisco lose to
when when snowy Joey was thrown every
year New Orleans would always beat the
[ __ ] out of them at home or away when
San Francisco is on the top of their
game they could not beat the New Orleans
Saints the New Orleans Saints beat them
they go into the NFC playoff with the
Cowboys guess what I'm at a [ __ ] bar
doing blow I'm 18 years old and I donned
on me at this bar I go wait a second
what you mean to tell me is that the
Dallas Cowboys are gone into candlestick
and they're gonna try to tell us no we
Joey and those [ __ ] savages a story
that's when they had Dwight that Miss
Chloe dude that's when they had that
nickel [ __ ] defense with Ron lot who
his finger was broken and they people
who would cut off that [ __ ] piggies
are you Japanese okay okay
Japanese people they cut that [ __ ]
pinkies off yeah like when they [ __ ] up
you like you [ __ ] up you dishonored
your Sava they couldn't pick you up a
brother cut his pinky off during a
[ __ ] game and you didn't look me in
the face and tell me that the Dallas
Cowboys are gonna go into the airfield
and beat him by one well and I remember
there was a kid who hated me he's dead
now Anthony Kruger he died yeah he was
me robbing his house an Eightball from
his house I never robbed him [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him I don't give a [ __ ] he's dead
[ __ ] let him roast in hell for sell and
blow so he [ __ ] he was a big cowboy
fan and he kept trying to like he was
tough kid he could have gone what if the
Cowboys win can I beat the [ __ ] out of
here and this kid was it's like Brendan
saying this to me and I'm gonna beat you
up oh he hated me but he couldn't touch
me
I had juice behind me in those days yeah
he couldn't just come into our beat numb
because he had a 16 [ __ ] behind
so I said to him let me ask this how
[ __ ] up I was like oh let me ask you
this what if San Francisco beats him can
I come to your house and punch you in
the [ __ ] face
that's how ballsy I was that night
because right there and dawned on me
that San Francisco was gonna beat the
Cowboys at home then we're not gonna go
and then cover one and what happened
that game that's the most famous
catching yeah the one o'clock reached
out and I had the old and I had the over
son what's up saw some things you go
push that dude in the face oh no I
didn't see him after I saw him at the
hospital one time he is laying here a
bummer as Dwight Clark just can't see I
said yeah you know I'll brain trauma
when I lived well what did you expect
mark you went through trucks yeah that
dude went through [ __ ] trucks mm I
was living in San Francisco I was on the
lam they were looking for me in Boulder
for credit-card [ __ ] and I'm living in
the head and the Tenderloin I'm living
with rough areas this dog this is 85
when the worst violence I had ever seen
in my life I saw a guy get sliced open
I saw another guy in front of original
Joe's and the Tenderloin with brown
blood coming out of him there was a
[ __ ] dude from Cuba cuz Cuban
refugees had just come from Mariel
Harbor and they own this street and they
had what boo got wrong as a Bouguereau
as a guy that has gay boyfriends but
they just suck his dick they don't [ __ ]
him in the ass he [ __ ] em in the ass
but he's not gay it's a jailhouse thing
in Cuba and he puts wigs on his [ __ ]
that day or no whoa no this is the Cuban
mentality like they suck my dick and I
[ __ ] him in the ass
yeah I'm a man so this guy was a Cuban
coke dealer and he had two of these gay
guys as his assistants and he would
sucked and he was a family man he had
kids at the house birthday time but you
know with these two guys with wigs in
the day old beard and he and they say
[ __ ] up he was just back hand them and
[ __ ] the street and their wig would fall
off you know that [ __ ] dude Richie
Ramirez that killed people the night I
want to buy a nickel bag in the 10
and the FBI came in and goes you got to
get out of here the FBI was waiting for
him that's where he stayed damn when he
would stay in the tenderloin was badass
it's still rough today I'm not like back
then but they have a they have a tad
Steakhouse they used to be big in New
York now it's like eating the [ __ ]
scab or foot a [ __ ] terrorist foot or
something but tad Steakhouse was good
and across the street there was a gym
and I would go to that gym in 85 and
Dwight Clark used to work out there I
might hug them one then I go dog you
covered the spread for uncle Joey big
uncle Joey for everybody I started
yelling at this gym they were gonna come
and beat you they are suck my daddy
loved it or he loved it he goes I
thought the same thing
Lakers do nothing legend man legend
[ __ ] pick but that's when I decided
I'm like where that's just like life you
ain't gonna come into my [ __ ]
Stadium mm-hmm and tell me what time is
crackalacking yeah yeah and I decided
that when I was like 22 I'm like that's
it it's old that's the right attitude
though you're not coming into my stadium
my rules are my rules it's like texting
you need to text me till you're green
ain't gonna answer you back dude doesn't
that answer you back all yeah I'll call
you I love it man so I have I've gone to
sprint and they found missing Texas and
I feel like calling the people no you
can't be that stupid that you text me
eight times but never call me you should
deserve it is weird you should die yeah
you're worthless you asked me for the
end you text me to the [ __ ] end when
you see my back ripple and I pull myself
up like a champ like a champ through 30
times fast while talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a gif it sagg if it's a gift